we begin with the breaking news overseas
three Americans held prisoner by North
Korea are on their way home they were
freed today and walked on their own from
a van onto the plane of Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo at the end of his day
long visit that included a brief meeting
with kim jeong-hoon president Trump is
grateful for their release right now
flying back are three what they were
calling hostages we call them fine
people we really find people seem to be
healthy they'll be landing at two
o'clock in the morning at Andrews Air
Force Base and I'll be there to greet
them nobody thought this was going to
happen and if it did it would be years
or decades frankly nobody thought this
was going to happen and I appreciate kim
jeong-hoon doing this their return
clears the way to an historic upcoming
summit between the president and kim
jeong-hoon mr. Trump had some news
earlier on when that meeting will be
taking place within three days within
three days we're just working
arrangements but it will not be there a
lot of good things can happen a lot of
bad things can happen I believe that we
have both sides want to negotiate a deal
I think it's going to be a very
successful deal Gregg president Trump
was not going to go to this meeting
if these detainees were still being held
by the North Koreans so this was the a
smart move by the North Koreans if they
really want to have it mm-hmm
and yeah that's good I think the New
York Times should be relieved to know
that we're Pompeo was because I believe
that they were like where's Pompeo why
isn't he here with the Iranian deal
because he was doing something else I
have Sarah Sanders on tape talking about
that earlier - did I jump the gun no not
at all but you act it's actually the
perfect segue let's listen to it oh the
fact that I'm standing here taking
questions the fact that the president
took questions from your colleagues just
two hours ago demonstrates this White
House's commitment to accessibility and
to providing information to the American
public at the same time the press has a
responsibility to put out accurate
information just yet
today the New York Times accused the
Secretary of State for being a wall a
wall when he was flying across the globe
to bring three Americans home there is
an outrageous claim she's making your
point yes you know I think the media may
have to admit that despite all the flaws
of Trump that they seem to cover
obsessively on other channels the United
States elected a person with a unique
skill set that is perfect for these
kinds of events he may not be Ward
Cleaver you know he may not be Marcus
Welby MD trying to hit the audience but
he has a skill set that presidents our
past presidents may not have had and
it's time to move on and kind of accept
that this is what he might be good at
get over the two-year tantrum we might
need some anti grief counselors in the
media to cheer these people up well I do
it is an interesting thing Pete that you
have an optimist historic opportunity
and you do wonder if people will be able
to get over any sort of politics in
politics or it's infusing everything
that we do at all the times but
everybody can be happy that these three
you should be Chinese are coming home
the way you look at it you're welcome
for fire and fury you're welcome for the
bloody nose approach you're welcome for
the military exercises you're welcome
for all the fear and the end and the
craziness the so-called mainstream media
had he's gonna bring us to nuclear
Armageddon no he's not he's gonna scare
the bejeebers out of kim jeong-hoon and
so he actually finally comes to the
table and makes all these concessions up
front before we even have a talk
that shows how serious they are about
the fact that they believe that
President Trump might actually take away
their nukes or bomb them if necessary
that's the necessary prerequisite for
actual peace so it takes a perception of
a crazy man to bring a real crazy man to
the table to actually bring peace would
it be cheaper and figure that out but
jeepers ya know it's a midwestern trap
for something else he's following in
Greg's footsteps the whole demo thing
next was like laughs that he goat
Junction
do you think that the president is
willing to tap the brakes on people
getting a little bit overly exuberant
thinking that world peace is at hand and
the North Koreans are going to do
everything that is asked of them when
they come to the table I mean he does
always say you just heard him right
before we started there could be a lot
of good things that happened there could
be a lot of bad things that happen and
he's trying to show everyone that the
keys he's aware that the North Koreans
have a penchant for lying
yeah he should be but you know so I
think everybody has high hopes that this
that those people are in good health
obviously our Lee warmbier was not in
good health the president though said
people didn't think this could happen
decades I mean these people have been
held since 15 I think is the the longest
17 for two of the people who are coming
home you just think you thank God that
this is happening because we know that
the North Koreans do not treat prisoners
fairly but I think it's a crazy Nair say
oh it's because of president Trump's
bellicose rhetoric that somehow you see
the North Korean suddenly acting more
graciously I think the fact is it's
sanctions
I think it's pressures we had we had
we've had sanctions on these are
different years these are sanctions on
companies getting China kimberley to
come on but I think that even with that
the president somehow I mean things get
stepped on you know so yesterday it was
the Iran deal and by the way New York
Times and their story said Pompeii was
on his way to North Korea to hopefully
bring home three people so I don't know
why you want to pick on the time I think
the headline was different okay but
anyway the article I only read the
headlines one of your stories
Dorian's millennial with the people with
the people but the people meanwhile also
we got the the story about money Russian
money being funneled to Michael Cohen
steps on again on the good news about
the north only in the CNN NEWSROOM
no great man do you see what happens
here see bond is like master you got to
keep your eyes on both hands because
he'll distract he'll deflect and you're
like wait a second yes I'm talking about
this this is what the facts
residents accomplishment is here we
should be celebrating the fact that
these three Americans came home good
health prosperity that is remain
internationally yes and with information
so this is something when you look at
the type of diplomacy it's almost like a
destabilizing diplomacy that he engages
in because it isn't anything that
anyone's seen before experienced before
so it throws the other side off their
game they're not sure what to expect or
anticipate and that really is the secret
to his success as it relates to foreign
policy and what we've seen in terms of
how he's handled himself diplomatically
and working with other countries like
wait a second we better take this
seriously and pay attention because he's
liable to just do about anything we
don't go by the typical playbook that
we've been used to seeing and one you
say he steps on his good news with other
news he steps on good news with more
good news so he scraps the Iran deal and
within that same day he's bringing back
three hostages in a way that opens up
the possibility for possibly you don't
know but an opening on the Korean
Peninsula which hasn't happened for
previously minute so I think of it just
the opposite I thought he was saying the
good news is the release of the
prisoners yes and what he's done then
everybody instead is frightened about
what is going on with Iran does he have
a plan B does he have an understanding
we seem to have separate or sell a safe
I mean the critics have been all over
this right especially the Democrats
right so from President Obama oh can I
interrupt and all right as you guys are
so good at moving me along today
President Trump is getting a lot of
harsh criticism for pulling out of the
Iran deal from leaders who helped
negotiate it and other powerful
Democrats as Hwan was saying President
Obama says the pullout risks eroding
America's credibility John Kerry says it
breaks America's word and Nancy Pelosi
says that in dangers global security
defies comprehension so I'll turn to you
Greg on all right so if you're mad about
Iran and what happened who should you
blame a you blame Obama who left his
party in tatters which enabled President
Trump to be elected to you'd blame
Hillary who thought the election was in
the bag so they didn't they assumed that
this this deal was going to stay because
they were gonna have Hillary in there
and gotta blame Anthony Weiner because
he presented the last
dandled exactly so all of that if you
mad don't be mad at Donald Trump because
he said he was gonna do this be mad at
yourselves for creating a deal that
could be reversed
that wasn't really a deal but just
basically yeah not treat whatever
handshake it was but it's great I loved
I look I can't tell who's more
hysterical the media the Democrats or
the Iranians burning flags I saw how
Iran's supreme leader said that trumps
corpse will be worm food I think he's
auditioning for Morning Joe that's
exactly what I hear to you on this about
why you know the State Department had a
person there a political appointee there
with the Europeans trying to explain to
them that they want to do a different
deal try to get to something where they
could agree on the sunset provision
remember on this deal on Obama's deal
you would the it would sunset and so 10
years the Iranians would be able to get
a nuclear weapon right after that and
I'm curious if you have any insight as
to what it was that the Europeans were
so resistant about changing that sunset
provision I think they're resistant
about changing anything that throws a
deal that they are totally invested in
that they feel good about the legacy of
a deal that they got that Barack Obama
got who's their international friend and
it's difficult to change a deal like
they also they're also making a lot of
money Kimberly there's a lot of economic
activity that was allowed under this
deal yeah Europeans in particular well
absolutely so you can understand that
and when President Trump said okay I
understand that you know if I were they
might be upset too but he's got to act
in the best interests of the United
States and what he sees is our you know
global future and the national security
and safety of Americans and quite
frankly the world this was not a good
deal I would really shudder at the
thought that a president who researched
it met with people discussed it and
decided to make this decision didn't
make it because he was afraid of the
criticism or that people would say oh
wow now that what you've done you've
torn down a legacy portion of Barack
Obama I mean it wasn't well thought out
to begin with the president shouldn't
stick in a bad deal that's why he also
pulled out at the Paris climate change
accord because he analyzed that need did
the numbers and as I said yesterday and
I just do not think that we should in
fact fund a nuclear Iran especially when
they were not you know honest as related
to their inspections or anything else
their self inspecting it was absolutely
ridiculous so it wasn't something that
was really good for the United States
are quite frankly the world well let me
just say I said my concern and I saw
this in the papers today is is President
Trump
acting in the interest of the United
States as opposed to simply being
vindictive and say I don't like Obama I
don't like the pass deal this is
horrible I I'm a deal maker I can create
chaos and make people come to the table
on my terms because wait a second does
it really make us more secure
remember twice this president has
certified that Iran didn't violate any
of the terms of the deal each day
Europeans we might have been reluctant
finish Pete so then the Europeans and
the International Atomic Energy all say
no evidence of any violation the
president speaks yesterday he doesn't
have an ambulance instead he says rotten
deal horrible deal I'll get a better
deal but what do we see right now we see
the United States isolated from its
allies President Obama said the real
choice here is a nuclear Iran or we go
to war which is what you know Netanyahu
once we go to war with Iran to take them
out he just hugged Abel izing the Middle
East hugged it out with Emmanuel macron
Bibi Netanyahu loves the deal we're not
isolated from it and you have to
understand this is the pattern that
we've seen start he comes in creates the
chaos by turning the table over that
turns to a certain kind of uncertainty
so when you start to negotiate the other
side doesn't know what you're doing and
he's left the door open so this is exact
I would I see this as kind of a replay
of North Korea the North Korea starts
begins with chaos and uncertainty and
the media and the Democrats are going
world war three oh there's more likely
to war this is a complete deja vu we
will live through this six months ago
let him do a new deal I mean okay a real
good deal let him do a good deal let him
do a deal based on the benefit of
experience that what he's learned from
this deal what they think works and
doesn't work I'm not a big fan of you
know Iran self-certifying saying yep no
violations here from us wink wink while
they're continuing to build a new clue
Iran that's that's the bottom line here
so let the president go through it make
strong choices based on facts and
information he did win the election it
is his prerogative he's got a team in
place now that he can work with to make
some solid decisions as it relates to
nationally the problem is you want to
negotiate a deal with North Korea on
guess what nuclear disarmament oh but we
stepped out of a deal that we signed
just a few years ago and everybody in
the world now is going to negotiate a
new deal with Iran because Iran
apparently is interested in maintaining
that deal for maybe many of the reasons
that shows the world we want a real deal
nada nada but they don't nobody says it
was a bad deal except President Trump
was a political promise what happens